hi i'm derek downey a developer advocate
for google cloud
i am currently working on developing a
banking application that leverages cloud
spanner the highly scalable managed
relational database from google cloud
in the previous video i set up a
regional spanner instance with a small
amount of compute capacity for
developing my banking application
i also created a customers database on
the instance and all the tables related
to my app will live in this database
now my company might have other internal
only data completely unrelated to my
banking app
that data could be placed in a separate
database because spanner instances can
have multiple databases
databases are a way to organize related
tables together and to provide
additional access control to the data
stored on the instance
for example my banking app should
definitely not have access to the
internal database
besides access control each database can
be configured with different options
that affect the performance recovery and
security of your database
these options control the optimizer
version version retention period and
database encryption
the first database option is the
optimizer version
the optimizer's job is to create an
execution plan that is an efficient way
to retrieve data from spanner based on
the given sql query
it has a direct impact on performance of
requests issued to your database
over time the query optimizer will
change to improve the accuracy of the
estimates required to create this
execution plan
when spanner releases a new optimizer
version the default behavior is for
databases to use the new version 30 days
after release
optimizer versions can change the
performance of your query workload
so it's important to compare query
performance of the new version with the
older version
you can pin the optimizer version a
database uses to a specific version by
altering the database
altering the database optimizer version
to null resets to the default behavior
of updating 30 days after the release of
a new version
you can also change the optimizer
version for individual queries by
providing the optimizer version query
hint
this is useful to validate queries where
stable performance is critical without
changing the optimizer version for the
entire database
another important database option is the
version retention period which affects
the ability to perform a point in time
recovery
by default spanner will maintain all
versions of the data and schema for one
hour in my banking application i want to
protect against accidental data loss
with spanner's default retention i have
an hour to copy the data as it existed
before an accidental change and then
load it back into the database
during normal business operations this
hour might be enough
but what about during off hours or the
weekend
i might not be able to respond in time
to avoid data loss
so i want to be sure to size my version
retention period to give my team enough
time to recover outside of normal hours
one way to do this would be to set the
version retention period according to my
backup frequency
for instance if i take a backup of my
database once a day then i will want to
set my version retention period to one
day
the last option i will cover is how
encryption is handled for spanner
databases
all data in spanner is encrypted at rest
by default this encryption is handled
for you by google cloud
however if you have specific compliance
or regulatory requirements on the keys
encrypting the data spanner offers the
ability to deploy your own encryption
keys
these are called customer managed
encryption keys and are managed through
google cloud kms
it is possible to have some databases
configured with customer encryption keys
while other databases on the same
instance use google cloud to manage
encryption
up and managing these custom encryption
keys is beyond the scope of this video
but there are some important pieces of
information when using custom encryption
keys
first a database must be created with
the custom encryption key
custom encryption keys cannot be enabled
on an existing database
second for backups the primary version
of the encryption key at the time of
backup creation
is used to encrypt backups
finally encryption keys must be
available to decrypt the database and
backups
if a key is deleted and can't be
recovered any spanner database or backup
encrypted with that key is unrecoverable
for now i will be using the default
encryption managed by google cloud for
my banking application
cloud spanner offers the ability to
organize related data into multiple
databases on your spanner instance
this provides some additional control
over who has access to the data stored
there
in this video i went over some other
options that give you more control over
the performance recovery and security of
your spanner database in our next video
i will go into more detail about the
spanner schema including data types data
organization and schema management
in the meantime please let us know in
the comments if you have any questions
around database specific options in
spanner
[Music]
you